vous sentez-vous parfois forcé de donner
un gros pour boire chez certains
commerçants quand on vous tend le
terminal pour payer l'organisation
visuelle de l'information vous incite à
choisir le pourcentage le plus élevé par
exemple en choisissant 15% ici vous vous
sentirez généreux alors qu'en
choisissant le même pourcentage lent
vous vous sentirez radin les commerçants
font ça parce que ça marche regardez ça
devant cet écran si vous souhaitez
donner 15%, vous devez passer par une
étape de plus devant l'employé malaise
bref plus les pourcentages suggérés sont
élevés plus la clientèle est généreuse
mais elle aura aussi l'impression qu'on
lui a tortue le bras selon une étude
récente et cette spécialiste met les
commerçants en garde contre la tentation
de jouer sur nos sentiments pour nous
soutirer plus d'argent parce que
l'insatisfaction des clients pourrait se
retourner contre eux et leur attirer des
critiques surtout pour ceux qui
calculent le pourcentage sur le montant
incluant les taxes ou encore au comptoir
pour emporter alors cher marchand même
si le pourboire est une norme dans
certains secteurs vos clients le
considèrent toujours comme un geste
volontaire qu'ils ne veulent pas se
faire imposer passer le mot
[Musique]